director Tim Miller recently announced
that a trailer for Terminator 6 dark
fade with Arnold Schwarzenegger and
Linda Hamilton will be released soon
the film's official Twitter channel
featured a photo from the editing room
showing Hamilton in her role as Sarah
Connor with a bazooka on her shoulder
underneath is a statement by Miller
which reads as follows I like to spend
every Terminator day in a dark room
thinking dark thoughts and our Edit Bay
is the perfect place we were here
putting the finished touches on our
first trailer we're just weeks away from
releasing this [ __ ] into the wild and
we're very very excited however they
seem to have missed out on an exact date
for the first trailer as Miller's few
lines unfortunately don't reveal this
but if you believe the statements it
won't take too long hopefully we learn a
bit more about the plot because so far
it's only known that she was an egg row
and Hamilton will return to their couch
rows but nothing more the plot will be
located directly after Terminator 2 as
it has been known for quite some time on
November 1st 2019 you will be able to
see Terminator 6 dark fade in cinemas in
the US since the release of the eighth
season Game of Thrones the opinions of
some fans have been increasing that they
expected more from the final season of
the series which has been broadcasted
since 2011 on change.org a user named
Dylan has even started a petition which
demands a remake of the last season in
the info Tex it says concrete David
Benioff and DB Weiss have proven
themselves to be woefully incompetent
writers when they have no source
material to fall back on this series
deserves a final season that makes sense
subvert my expectations and make it
happen HBO by Thursday more than 270
thousand other dissatisfied fans had
signed the petition the core of the
frustration is above all that the
current final season is not based on the
book by george RR martin but entirely
written by the screenwriters despite
hundreds of thousands of signatures it
is very unlikely that the fans will be
successful with their petition
nevertheless many people claim that the
sonic producers have recently been
persuaded to change the appearance of
the protagonist
however HBO probably will not give in
and produce a completely new ad season
just because some fans are disappointed
if you look at the ratings of the
internet platform Rotten
my toes it becomes clear that the
euphoria of the first season has clearly
decreased while the first season has a
score of 94% the eighth season only has
a score of 71 percent nevertheless we
are curious to see how the game of
Thrones saga will be brought to a close
in the u.s. on May 19th
Pokemon detective Pikachu has already
broken some records with a taking in
result of 58 million u.s. dollars the
video game adaption around the yellow
pokemon now holds the record for the
most successful starting weekend of the
game adaption in the USA and even passes
Larrick rough Tom Brady released in 2001
on a global scale the start weekend was
also worth it as the Master Detective
with Ryan Reynolds voice earned one
hundred and seventy million u.s. dollars
worldwide but not only the box office
results but also the rib you speak for
the film especially in comparison to
other video game adaptions on Rotten
Tomatoes Master Detective Picacho is the
only film adaption listed as fresh for
all those who haven't seen it yet the
film has been shown in cinemas since May
10 2019 it's no secret that the John
wick series is currently one of the most
popular action films the reason for this
is not only shooting star Keanu Reeves
but also tough an elaborately staged
action which is unsurpassable at the
moment this is also being reflected in
the edge rating because it seems that
the third part is still on the trail of
its immediate predecessor as we know now
the firm is already
thus shortly before its release the
movie shows once again that no
compromises will be made in the upcoming
third part and therefore they can maybe
even attract some undecided action fans
to the cinema he magically however the
movie also has a lot of its lead after
all after a dishonorable murder the
whole underworld and with it also former
colleagues are pretty keen on killing
the killer and grabbing the bounty of 14
million US dollars with an advantage of
only one hour rick has to gain the
greatest possible advantage in order to
not end up as a corpse himself if John
we can do that we can see on Thursday
May 24th 2019 in the cinemas
one of the most popular family comedies
of the late 80s will get a reboot which
will be Honey I Shrunk the Kids for
those of you who belong to Generation Y
rather than Generation X here's a little
summary the kinky scientist when
Solinsky has accidentally shrunk his two
children Amy and Nick as well as some
children from the neighborhood from now
on they have to find their way in the
world that is full of dangers like
suddenly oversized insects the only
downside of this family comedy is that
the special effects are no longer up to
date that's another reason why Disney
thought it wasn't a bad idea to produce
a reboot of the comedy the story of the
new strip is supposed to be set in the
same universe as its original
predecessor and the two sequels but this
time it's not Wayne but Nick Solinsky is
now grown-up son boost the cause of the
disaster he is supposed to be
impersonated by Josh GAD who last worked
in Beauty and the Beast as well as
frozen by the way everyone who suspect
another exclusive Disney Plus movie can
relax because that's probably not the
case in fact Schrank is supposed to be a
movie however the release date will
probably not be before 2020
[Music]